foreign
[Music]
orders
and you've got us
[Music]
and follow us
what you can't understand
your sons and your daughters
[Music]
please get out of the new one
for the times
[Music]
eyes
sausages
[Music]
homeless
Ness
[Music]
foreign
dire
ctor
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
together
yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
Madam president your excellencies
honorable ministers distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen friends from all
over the world I'm truly honored to
warmly welcome you to this name giving
ceremony of the world's first green
container vessel
today we've all been looking immensely
forward to in a day and an achievement
that many of you in this tent and
watching online have worked so hard to
collectively make possible a truly happy
proud and historic moment in the world
of shipping
my name is Camila hulsa and I'm the head
of public policy and Regulatory Affairs
at mosque but today I'll be the one to
guide you through our program
and what you just witnessed a moment ago
was the Danish female choir unglang
beautifully performing Bob Dylan's the
times are changing and the Danish song
it Denmark airfood which means in
Denmark I was born
and what better way to set the scene for
today's event Bob Dylan's song about a
call for Action about accepting and
acknowledging that times are changing
and the Danish song written by our
national poet hence Christian Anderson
as a tribute to his home country
Denmark a leading and pioneering green
Nation will also be the home state of
our new vessel that'll proudly carry the
Danish flag
our program today includes speeches from
the chairman of apamilo Mr Robert ookler
the CEO of FMLA musk Mr Vincent Clerk
and the president of our of the European
commission our guest of honor and the
soon to be godmother of the vessel
missile fundalian
the distinguished speakers represent an
essential Trinity for a green future
the courage for long-term commitment the
ability to execute and the foresight to
establish the necessary framework
conditions
after the speeches we'll have the
official name-giving ceremony just
outside and after that they'll be guided
tours on board the vessel then we'll end
by having a standing networking launch
I'll come back with much more practical
information but already now there's some
important safety instructions please
take note of where the emergency exits
are and in case of any emergency their
security staff on site to help and guide
us
but now without further Ado I'll invite
our first Speaker the chairman of April
Miller mersk to come on stage and share
with us some of your Reflections on the
green transition a topic that I know is
close to your heart Mr Robert peace
[Applause]
thank you Camila
Madam president
your excellencies
honorable ministers
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen Friends of the house
on behalf of April emergency on this
beautiful day I'm deeply honored to
Welcome All of You
thank you for being here on this
important day for the naming of the
world's first containership designed to
sail on green fuse
your participation not only adds to the
significance of this occasion but also
underscores the power of unity and the
power of collaboration
as we jointly address what I think many
of us believe is Our Generations biggest
challenge
we're here to celebrate a ship
but in all fairness it is fairly modest
in size
as mentioned to Madame President when we
entered attempt
this video is only about 10 percent of
what the biggest container ships usually
carry it holds a nominal capacity of
around
2100 20-foot containers
so it is a leadership
with that said
while it is fairly small its importance
and its impact transcend its physical
dimensions
trade is an integral part of human
history having connected communities for
thousands of years
trade enables critical supplies to reach
what would other be what would otherwise
be isolated corners of the world
and trade
creates jobs
when entrepreneurs and companies find
markets for their products
close to 90 percent of all trade is
ocean based
moving Goods I see is by far the most
effective environmentally friendly mode
of transportation
however given the scale of Ocean trade
it comes with a significant carbon cost
in total close to three percent of the
world's greenhouse gases
are emitted from ships
now this is not a recent development
in fact for almost 150 years our supply
chains have been highly dependent on
fossil fuels
the first ship to sail with a mask star
on its formal
was named Laura
Laura was propelled by a cold-based
steam engine
she was designed during the Industrial
Revolution which transformed how we
produced and consumed energy as a
society
some year some years later our group
ordered the first ship with a diesel
engine an equally significant technology
today
more than a century later
we Embrace a new few
similar to Laura the steamship Laura
this ship represents an industrial
revolution yet of a green character
two and a half years ago men in our
industry argued that liquefied natural
gas was the future fuel for shipping
LNG as we call it is still a fossil fuel
and it's maintain sleep is considered
highly damaging to the environment
at the time many did not see any green
alternatives
a lot has happened in the last few years
and in my humble View
this very ship
has become the Catalyst for such a
change
next year from January onwards Maersk is
taking delivery of a series of much
bigger ships
all all to Salem green methanol
and equally important there is now a
broad and growing followership
across our industry as we speak more
than 170 ships are about to be built or
are being built or retrofitted to sail
on green methanol
and we're not just talking about
container ships but also box ships
cruise ships Paris forecasts tankers
hopefully
and that is our
aspiration and ambition this is the
beginning of a green revolution of our
Global Supply chains
together with Partners in this room
and elsewhere we are exploring other
Pathways to decarbonize trade including
other fields
with that said the most important
question is no longer how to develop new
technologies but rather how to speed up
the implementation of the solutions
available
or to be more direct as highlighted by
the former U.S president agour the
question is not how to solve the climate
crisis but whether we would do it in
time
to successfully transition away from
fossil fuels we must jointly address the
next big Challenge and that is to enable
and scale the world's supply of
brilliant views
and let me just illustrate the magnitude
of this challenge
by 2030
merge alone needs approximately 5
million tons of green fuels
and that is a real requirement given the
audiobook we now have
today the Global Production
of free methanol is below a hundred
thousand tones
the off take requirements for
greenfields from ourselves and others in
shipping are huge no company no investor
will be able to pull this off by
themselves
of course we need the support of our
many customers to be successful our
customers have to embrace green
Transport Solutions
but probably most importantly our
industry needs strong regulatory
Frameworks and the right incentives this
is truly critical
I'm very grateful for the significant
efforts of Madame President
Madam president's colleagues
and the government of Denmark
in this respect
and some good examples of the progress
we're seeing is the inclusion of
shipping in the in the new ETS framework
as well as Imo's recently revised
greenhouse gas reduction strategy
adopted at the mepc meeting this summer
I also value the ongoing dialogues in
the EU and elsewhere in the world about
the necessary industrial policies
required
across the value chain to enable the
production of competitive green views
the investment in production and
infrastructure
um
facilities represent a major opportunity
to establish new new green Industries
we must make sure these Investments
happen
as we Face obstacles on our journey
ahead let us be reminded and encouraged
by a common purpose
the primatologist and Anthropologist
Jane Goodall once said we have not
inherited this planet from our parents
rather we are borrowing it from our
children
with this in mind I sincerely think our
many many passionate colleagues Partners
but also officials for valued
collaboration
and for your Relentless efforts to turn
the tide on climate change
you have my deepest respect
and finally let me say we're also deeply
honored that Madam president has decided
to attend this historic Milestone and
accept it to become godmother of this
ship thank you
thank you
thank you Mr chairman for the inspiring
words about why the world needs the
green transition and what it'll take to
get us there we now have the vessel but
we still need to solve around the cost
competitive green fuels and that'll be
crucial especially for a familiar musk
and its incoming Fleet of green vessels
and who better to talk about that and
what it'll take to complete the green
transition from a business perspective
then the CEO of apamilarmersk so Mr
Vincent Clark I kindly ask you to come
on stage thank you
[Applause]
but I'm president
your excellencies honorable ministers
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen and Friends of the house
today marks a significant moment for AP
molomersk
but perhaps more importantly an
inflection point for an entire industry
an industry often linked to its
environmental impact environmental
impact and rightfully so
across the entirety of the global supply
chain from Planes to trucks to railroads
ports and warehouses the logistics
industry accounts for 11 of the global
carbon emission
as just highlighted by our chairman
shipping alone a hard to Abate sector
makes up three of those 11 percent
The Vessel we celebrate today is a
crucial first step towards a solution
for the shipping industry
but also a step that may encourage and
outline a path forward for other hard to
evade sectors
in 2018 when AP model mursk announced
its industry first commitment
we frankly did not have a path to get to
zero
our ambition back then was to get our
first methanol ship in the Water by
2030.
well
it wasn't easy but we found a path
and today we know how to achieve climate
neutrality
and we are and what we are most pleased
about is the followership that this ship
has seen from the entire industry
in the next few years this bioning ship
behind us will be joined by more than a
hundred methanol container vessels
ordered by various companies
all dedicated to climate neutrality
trajectory
the strong and Rapid involvement from
the industry is essential to accelerate
the Innovation and Adoption of new
technologies
this is fundamentally required to meet
our goals
I am convinced that with this ship we
are entering a phase where multiple
Technologies and solutions can coexist
side by side in the same ecosystem while
collectively reducing emissions
the first vessel strongly demonstrates
that if you want to go beyond you need
to go together
the list of contributors to bring this
ship to life is very long
I want to start by expressing my
gratitude to our majority owner and our
Board of Directors for the on for their
unwavering support and trust that you
have extended as we embarked on the
decarbonization journey
what seems intuitive today
was not a few years ago
but you supported us all the way
furthermore I want to recognize the hard
work done by so many colleagues across
Maersk and not least the Maersk crew
making its first historic Journey
from South Korea to Copenhagen
Captain Peter Wilhelm van rein and
Captain Brian Sorensen and their crew
representing all of our highly and
dedicated seafarers
today's historic Milestone is indeed a
testament to the collaborative efforts
and unwavering supports from our partner
organization
I'd like to extend my deepest gratitude
to our honored partner the Korean
Shipyard Hyundai maple dockyard
to our main engine supplier man Energy
Solutions to the auxiliary engine
supplier Hyundai heavy Industries engine
Machinery division
let me also acknowledge the pivotal role
of our fuel supplier oci Who provided
the methanol for this Maiden journey and
European energy the future primary fuel
supplier for this vessel
and until European European energies
plant in southern Denmark becomes fully
operational equinor will graciously step
in as a supplier
I also want to thank all Regulators who
contributed including the Danish
Maritime Authority for the Danish flag
and the American Bureau of shipping for
the vessel classification
thank you for helping us turn a vision
into reality
we set a new standard in the industry
and for being such a significant part of
this journey
across the globe almost 10 000 companies
have committed to reach Net Zero by
2050.
forty percent of Fortune 500 companies
have set binding targets
from a climate perspective from a human
perspective and from a commercial
perspective the only thing that makes
sense is to lean in and accelerate the
energy transition
in this transformation the backing of
our customer is vital
and I'd like to extend a genuine thank
you to our customers for not only
partnering with us but also for their
willingness to co-lead this journey
since 2019 we have offered low emission
products called Echo delivery designed
around green fuels compatible with our
current Fleet
the backing for this has been
overwhelming from the start
and hundreds of our most
forward-thinking customers are
committing to Eco delivery some even in
contracts that Encompass a hundred
percent of their shipping needs
what's equally important
to us is helping customers decarbonize
their entire supply chain end to end
as such our efforts are not only
addressing just the three percent
emission from Shipping but also the
broader eleven percent from the entire
Global Supply Chain
on land we are building green warehouses
electrifying our terminals
and we have close to 500 electric trucks
in service or in order at this time
at Sea our new green vessel that we are
celebrating today will give us valuable
experience with operation on green
methanol enabling greater impact once
fuel volumes are secured for the larger
vessels that we have in order
green methanol is our fuel of choice not
because
because it's our field of choice now
because it is the only scalable solution
that can meet the Net Zero requirements
neither we nor the climate can afford
complacency or waiting for other
solutions to emerge in the late 2020s
in the past two years we have locked
orders for 25 ships able to operate on
green methanol
19 of those are already in production
and they will be in the sea by 2025
transition in the propulsion of a vessel
is very rare
we have seen three major change in the
past 140 years of existence of our
company
and mursk has taken part in all three
they were all Revolution
but they all took time
now we embark on the next transition
this time as a first mover
we like to see it
as a testament that when we Unite
to determine efforts and Partnerships
a tangible and optimistic path forward
to a sustainable future will emerge
we have looked forward to this day
it is a long-awaited culmination of the
efforts of many individuals and years of
United work
yet we are acutely aware that this is
just a beginning
ahead lies even greater challenges
but as it is the case with all
significant advancements it starts with
one
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mr Vincent clerk we can do a
lot but we cannot do it alone both you
and the chairman mentioned the
importance of political will and
supporting EU and international
regulation
as a true Pioneer of the green
transition of Europe You've Been
instrumental in including shipping in
the green framework making this vessel
the living proof of the eu's green deal
in action
it's therefore my immense honor to
welcome the president of the European
commission Ms Ursula from the line to
the stage
foreign
Vincent
excellencies ministers distinguished
guests
it is such an honor for me to be here
today to Christian the world's first
green container ship
you have already heard from Robert and
from Vincent how important this moment
is
I couldn't agree more
just a few years ago a large vessel
sailing on green methanol would have
been unlikely perhaps even impossible
so what led us here
climate change and global warming are
not new phenomena
science and politics have been
discussing them
for decades
and for just as long we've all known
that we need to cut greenhouse gas
emissions
yet when I took office four years ago
the idea
of a net zero shipping sector
was nothing just but a dream
something was still missing to trigger
big investments in climate friendly
Technologies
you needed certainty
about the direction of travel
a clear route so that you could set
sails
and we answered your call
in 2019 the European commission put
forward the European green deal
not only with a Clear Vision for Europe
to become the first climate neutral
continent
but also with binding law
which all our 27 member states the
biggest economic block on Earth signed
up to
and this has created the predictability
you needed to act
under the wind deal we adopted several
legislative proposals to make the
shipping sector cleaner and more
sustainable
and it was mersk
who sees the opportunity with a famous
Danish foresight
two years ago as you said you ordered
the first methanol-powered ship
and before the end of this decade you
expect 25 of your vessels to sail on
green methanol
this will save
2.75 million tons of CO2 per year
and thanks to greenfields to be produced
here in Denmark by solar power
what an achievement
what you have achieved needed vision and
it needed leadership
and joining forces
we have all understood that we are in
this transition together
the European green deal aligns political
ambition and public investment with
private investment and innovation
and this beautiful ship is a first fruit
of this cooperation
and there is a second element I want to
highlight
not only did Merc see the direction of
treble
but Pioneers like you
are shaping the economy of the future
this event is a big deal not only for
Europe
but for the whole world
as you said 90 of the World Trade is
carried by sea international shipping
represents three percent of the global
greenhouse gas emissions
by successfully decarbonizing shipping
we're not only promoting our fight
against climate change
we're also creating new Supply Chains
new Industries and thousands of new good
jobs
and this is the reason why the European
green deal is delivering
because we are marrying ecological
responsibility
with Economic Opportunity
the next priority is to secure green
fuels as you said at scale
take hydrogen
by 2030 we aim to produce and import 20
million tons of renewable hydrogen each
year
in the European Union
this is possible because we are already
deploying renewable energy like never
before
this year
for the first time in Europe
we generated more electricity from wind
and sun
than from gas
and with abundant and affordable
Renewables there will of course be more
investment into alternative fuels like
green hydrogen like ammonia and like
methanol
and because shipping is global our
efforts don't stop at Europe
we worked hard
as you said within the international
Maritime organization towards ambitious
Global action
the agreement reached last July to cut
the carbon footprint of international
Maritime transport is a real Milestone a
real milestone
we have to build on that and combine it
with a robust Global pricing mechanism
for greenhouse gas emissions in the
maritime sector
and this will then protect first movers
like you are here at Maersk
it will Empower more Pioneers to follow
your example and sustainably sale at
high seas
and it could create not only Global
revenues for domestic innovation
but also support developing economies
and Emerging Markets
support them and innovating and in
coping with the Fallout of climate
change
dear guests
this ship
this moment
embodies Europe's decision to Pioneer
the fight against climate change
we're turning a noble generational task
into a new growth strategy
on this journey
Only The Horizon is our limit
I am confident
because we know our destination and our
sailing ships together
are on a clear course we count on you we
know we can rely on you so let's do the
action that is necessary thank you very
much
thank you madam president we're truly
grateful to have you in this historical
ceremony having you as the Godmother of
our vessel is a testament to your
personal commitment to the energies
transition of Europe and what we see as
public private partnership when it's
best
we now move on to the next part of the
agenda and I think the moment we've all
been waiting for namely the official
name-giving ceremony of the vessel
so ceremonial naming of ships is a
long-standing and very important Naval
tradition that dates back thousands of
years with varying specifics of course
but with the overall aim of ensuring the
crews and the vessel safety at sea
the ceremony that you'll now witness
actually dates back to the Vikings so do
expect some noise and some horns
after the ceremony there'll be a
godmother photo and then the first group
will go on board the vessel while the
rest of us enjoy another performance by
the choir unclang that you heard before
then we'll all be guided to the launch
area where we'll have a standing lunch
where in parallel with the next groups
going on board the vessel
Madam president your excellencies
honorable ministers distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen
I now kindly require request you to
kindly exit the tent and there'll be
staff to guide you where to stand but
please approach the platform
and I think with that there's only left
for me to wish you all an enjoyable and
memorable name-giving event thank you
thank you
introduce you
in Korea they sometimes use facts but
you need a lot of force
oh
don't take too many steps backward yeah
Madam president
recognizing the values you represent for
Europe we are deeply honored that you
have accepted to become godmother for
this pioneering vessel
will you please do us the honor of
naming the vessel
I name you Laura Merc
as you sail the Waters of the world
may your Journeys be smooth
and your tasks successful
may you bring happiness to the crew
and be a safe heaven for all who bored
you
and may you bring prosperity and pride
to all
I wish you God speed
Anna and indeed
and the little ones now comes the big
moment you have to be here yes and
where's Emma
Ellen why don't you
come
where's the little one yeah
and now I try to press this
turn
yeah
look at this
I think we need one photo with the
family
and you know what you look to all these
people there
what I just pushed the button
I love it
you know what they can do
there we go
you know
so this ends the former ceremony let me
say a big thanks Madam president it was
a Flawless executed naming we're not
surprised this is a small Memento for
this historic Milestone and for your
support to our industry a big things
from our end
[Applause]
okay
okay apparently want one more footage
foreign
[Music]
down by the river by the boats where
everybody goes to be
another way you won't see any risings
[Music]
foreign
tell us your eyes to us
[Music]
and I don't know
Mercy however
[Music]
I don't know
foreign
[Music]
blue